AND HE IS CLOSED DOWN BY JETS
RATHER QUICKLY.
AND THE PUCK DEFLECTS OUT OF
PLAY.
AND AS HIS THIRD SEASON WITH THE
SERGEY KALININ.
AND BROKE UP BY SEVERSON.
B
BOUCHER KNOCKS OFF THE STICK.
AND IT'S THROUGH THE CREASE.
>> Kenny: I THINK HE WAS HOOKED
AT THE LAST SECOND.
IT WAS A SHARP ANGLE.
>> Steve: THAT IS JOHN McCLAIN
BETWE
BETWEEN THE BENCHES.
BLOCKED BY CAMMELLARI AND IT
WOULD NOT GO.
>> Kenny: OH, MY, MIKE
CAMMELLARI.
>> Steve: ZAJAC ON THE PUCK,
CARRIES BEHIND THE NET.
CORNER.
WAITS FOR ENSTROM.
TRYING TO MANEUVER AWAY FROM
GIONTA.
AND SHOT AND A SAVE MADE.
CHECK THAT.
PETAN IN THE SLOT, STOPPED BY
SCHNEIDER.
CENTERING TRY, TAKEN AWAY BY
>> Steve: EHLERS DROPS IT BACK
AND A QUICK SHOT, THEY SCORE.
EHLERS, WITH THE DROP PASS,
FINISHED BY MARK SCHEIFELE AND
THE JETS TAKE A 1-0 LEAD.
THEY ARE SAYING NO GOAL.
>> Kenny: I THOUGHT I SAW THE
NET.
OH, -- THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A
GOAL.
ZAJAC IS THE MAN ON THE SLOT.
CAMMELLARI, TAKEN BY THE DEVILS,
THEY SCORE.
TLUSTY AND THE DEVILS ARE ON THE
BOARD.
AND HERE IS PERREAULT, BACK FOR
LADD WHO SCORES.
ANDREW LADD WITH THE ONE-TIMER
AND THE POWER PLAY GOAL BY
WINNIPEG, MAKES IT 3-1 JETS.
>> Kenny: THIS IS REALLY TOO
BAD, THE DEVILS HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLEAR AND THE
AT IT, AND TAKEN BACK BY NEW
JERSEY, CENTERING PLAY BY HEN
ROOK.
AND HUTCHINSON IS ABLE TO DENY
THE DEVILS AT THE DOORSTEP.
>> Kenny: THAT WAS ENSTROM, WHO
LAID DOWN IN THE ICE, HENRIK
COULD NOT TAKE THE PASS CLEANLY,
ZAJAC, TRYING PLAY IT OFF THE
NEAR BOARDS AND BACK COME THE
JETS AND SHOOTING AND SAVE BY
SCHN
SCHNEIDER.
>> Kenny: TERRIFIC PASS FROM THE
GUY WE TALKED ABOUT.
HENRIQUE, CENTERING TRY, GOT BY
EVERYONE, INCLUDING TOOTOO,
SEVERSON PLAYS IT ACROSS, AND
HERE IS PALMIERI SHOT, STICK
MADE BY HUTCHINSON.
PICKED UP BY PALMIERI.
SEVERSON, WORKED IT TO THE
AWAY AND TAKEN IT BY MERRILL,
TRYING TO LIFT IT OUT OF THE
ZONE.
AND EHLERS PLAYS IT ACROSS, IN